Welcome back everyone marvel just released a
first look at the new secret invasion series
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here we'll
break down and i'll explain who the characters
are and how it's going to be different from the
comic book secret invasion and how this connects
with the events of spider-man no way home and
the spider-man far from home post-credit scene
i will be doing full episode videos for when it
releases next year so be sure to subscribe to
get everything real quick shout out to my friends
at raid shadow legends who asked to sponsor this
video if you have no idea what i'm talking about
there's a tiny super small hidden gem of a mobile
game you may not have heard of it called rage
shadow legends just a little hidden gem a free
hidden gem to start off raids releasing a bunch
of awesome new champions along with a brand new
faction wars crypt for the shadowkin on top
of that there's a ton of new year's events
and tournaments including a special fusion event
where you can get one of raid's newest legendary
champions recently raid has released its biggest
baddest scariest boss yet the hydra each of the
different heads has a different mechanic
to it and the whole battle is like a crazy
tactical puzzle box always revealing new
challenges in the middle of a fight it's
supposed to be one of the toughest fights in the
game but it's absolutely worth it because you can
get some of the best artifacts from this boss this
is the best time to get started in raid and if you
use my link in the description below or scan the
qr code right here that i'll put on screen in the
video should be right here new players will get
some free resources and a free mystery champion
straight away to kickstart your game all that free
stuff they give you you can find in your inbox in
the upper right hand corner right here so click
that link to find out who you get but in all these
new marvel previews that you probably saw versions
of in your timelines at some point in the last day
or two you can see nick fury maria hill taylor's
and emilia clarke's character she's playing
someone new from the comics that i'll explain in
a second all coming together in russia now they're
filming this in the uk but they're making it look
like russia i'll explain why in a second so when
they're running around on the streets here this
is meant to be russia like you look at all the
street signs the license plates all the signs it's
all in russian i know there are all these pictures
of spider-man running around in a costume in the
advanced suit on the set while this is going on
but this is not tom holland this is just a regular
cosplayer just a normal person who went full
yolo and ran around on the sets until security
escorted him off but it does make for some really
funny spider-man scroll theories but it's meant to
be the real nick fury this time this is what he's
going to look like at this point after the events
of spider-man no way home he's not wearing the eye
patch anymore and they're just showing you his bad
eyes scars and everything he has removed his eye
patch in the past before he showed us the bad eye
all the way back in captain america winter soldier
you need to keep both eyes open so it's not the
first time they've done this it's just that his
eye patch is such an iconic part of his costume
going way back in the comics that it's kind of
weird seeing him without it but it gives him this
more raw angrier look and he does look pissed off
in all this footage as you would expect nick
fury to be talos is also in his human form ben
mendelsohn obviously like we saw during the
captain marvel movie maria hill looks like
she just got into a fight has a few extra city
miles on her but she's back it is not meant to be
taylor's wife pretending to be her or anything it
really is the real version of maria hill you also
have to assume that if it was taylor's wife during
the spider-man far from home post-credit scene the
real maria hill was also probably also on that
scroll space station with the real nick fury
and as you all probably have guessed from emilia
clarke's green and pink looking shirt she's
wearing under her jacket it's a bit of a subtle
reference to the comic book character that she's
playing her character description just calls her
a confident spy with some powers and attitude
that can get in and out of situations with ease
and she's well trained and intelligent the current
best theory right now and a lot of you probably
had this theory after they first announced she
was joining the series is that she's playing the
mcu version of abigail brand who is from the x-men
comics and was the former head of sword which we
just saw in the wandavision series for the first
time they're like the mcu space version of shield
who's mostly tasked with protecting earth from
threats from outer space now they did something
different with them during the wandavision series
they kind of made sword seem like the villains
but they're not really a villainous organization
it's kind of like hydra taking over shield shield
itself was not evil it was just that people inside
shield were evil and using it for bad things
so even though tyler hayward created white
vision during the wandavision series inside sword
that doesn't mean the entire organization has now
been thrown in the garbage when amelia clark's
character description says she'll have powers
that will help her get in and out of situations
with ease abigail bran's powers in the comics
are tactile pyrokinesis she can generate flames
from her hands that are hot enough to burn through
metal and she has a tongue that can shape alien
languages on the fly which is what i think they
really mean when they say getting herself into
and out of trouble she could pass as either a
cree or a scroll in human form she could speak
their languages fluently whereas nick fury and
maria hill can't i'll explain the creep part in
a second too because i believe they're also going
to be using the secret invasion series to pay
off another really big spider-man far from home
easter egg that we haven't heard about since then
i thought cree having sleeper cells was top-secret
information because secret invasion was this huge
avengers crossover event i know a lot of you are
asking about them doing scroll versions of other
avengers characters they might have some jokes and
references to scrolls impersonating other avengers
in various points but kevin feige said this was
going to be more of a political thriller series
than a full-blown adventure series like the comic
book we're at interested in the in the paranoia
political paranoia aspect of secret invasion and
of course it will tie into other things and and
and the scrolls in ways you haven't seen before
so we're probably not going to see scroll versions
of all the avengers fighting together in a huge
battle or anything and in all this footage here
like i said they're filming scenes in the uk as
if it were russia and i believe it's meant to be
moscow this big celebration that they're putting
up here all these russian signs are saying that
it's national unity day which is a real holiday
in russia it's the date they used to commemorate
the end of the polish russian war in the early
1600s when they expelled the last of the forces
out of the country the end of the period that
they called the time of troubles when moscow had
been occupied by enemy forces for a long period so
the irony here is that they're in moscow and it is
still occupied after avengers end game and present
day while they're celebrating issues that is a
group of alien infiltrators occupying the city as
well as other pockets of them all over the earth
but the big twist here in the easter egg that i'm
talking about from spider-man far from home is
that i do not think that it's the skrulls who are
the villains of secret invasion even though that
is the comic book story i think they're actually
paying off the spider-man far from home easter
egg about the cree sleeper cells obviously it was
talos and his wife pretending to be nick fury and
maria hill when they were talking about the secret
of the cree sleeper cells but clearly at this
point in the timeline eight months after avengers
end game it's a big problem they're dealing with
and it also probably explains why nick fury was
with the cree on their space station they used the
entire captain marvel movie to say the mcu scrolls
weren't bad it was the cree who were bad nick fury
has been working with the cree in outer space ever
since the end of the captain marvel movie in the
90s like the space station he's on here is huge
it would have taken years to build the way they
ended that first captain marvel movie made it
sound like the cree would come back for their
revenge like a star wars empire strikes back
situation we'll get you in the future it sounds
like part of that plan involves all these cree
sleeper cells the secret invasion series is
supposed to be released right before the captain
marvel 2 movie the marvels and help set it up
so during the episodes they'll probably try to
root out all these cree sleeper cells and like
the bigger villains and that'll spin up to the
full-blown cree invasion plot during the captain
marvel 2 movie or they'll have some way of paying
that off during the movie that's also why we got
monica rambeau spectrum in wandavision last year
and we'll get miss marvel kamala khan later this
summer also to help set them up for the marvels
movie i haven't heard anything about amelia clark
coming back in the marvels but just like fellow
game of thrones alum jon snow kit harington's
black knight character is crossing over
in the blade movie after the eternals movie and
other movies like avengers 5. so i think the
idea is that they're setting up emilia clarke's
character to show up in future movies as well but
i don't expect them to have any kind of jon snow
and daenerys reunion anytime soon in any of the
big upcoming marvel projects like they did have a
jon snow rob stark reunion in the eternals movie
next time i see you you'll be all in black
it was always my color and so he did the
next time rob stark saw jon snow he was the black
knight talking about the spider-man no way home
connections in easter eggs so during the events
of spider-man no way home when spider-man gets
arrested by damage control and they're grilling
him about mysterio iron man's stark tech drones
peter yells at them to just contact nefuri he was
there for everything he saw it all he can tell you
what happened and the mysterio was responsible for
all this but in this scene here the damage control
agent says nick fury's been off planet since the
end of avengers end game basically peter did not
know he's like wait what what are you talking
about he's been off planet who was the person i
was talking to that entire time he still does not
know that it was talos pretending to be nick fury
side note too because of the way dr strange's
spell works because it basically erases everyone's
memories on earth of peter parker i know a lot
of you are asking does that mean if nick fury is
on his space station nick fury still remembers
peter parker i do not think that they're going
to address that at all during secret invasion
there might be some spider-man references but
i don't think they're going to get into the
idea of whether or not the spell affected him
the way the writers of spider-man no way home
explained that big twist is that they just kind
of left it for future movies to explore so when
they do spider-man 4 they'll just leave it to
whoever winds up writing that movie to explain how
powerful the spell is and who gets affected and
who is not affected so that just means that you're
free to theory craft about the way the spell works
if you have any other questions about what's
going on with this or the other marvel disney
plus series let me know in the comments next up is
going to be the marvel moon knight episodes i will
be doing full episode videos for that click here
to watch my full trailer breakdown for that it's
going to be awesome and click here for my eternals
deleted scene with kit harington's black knight
character thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!